hi I'm Andrew Stein Hawker i work at
Wolfram research and I'm going to be
talking about food and nutrition for
those of you who may not have been here
for last year's talk i gave a talk just
like this last year we've gone quite a
bit further since then which is why
there's a 2 in the title and I'd also
like to point out Brandon he helped out
a lot on this and there's a lot of other
names and faces even in this room that
have helped out a lot with this stuff so
don't don't assume that this is a
one-man show or anything like that
definitely a lot of thanks to them and a
lot of thanks to our food science
interns from the University of Illinois
as well so I'm so I guess to start out
I'll point out what I'm going to be
talking about today in a little more
detail first I'd like to give a quick
brief review over what we talked about
last year talk about some of the food
domains we have in the new entity
framework that was introduced in
Mathematica 10 as well as I'm up into
some of the new food data we have
involving packaged foods international
food some cooking equipment will hop
into a little bit of nutrient type
information that we have and sort of how
to package that all together into a nice
meal tracking sort of application so
I'll try and go breathe through this but
the the idea here is that we need to
have some place to store our nutritional
information and so we've introduced a
food entity type which basically stores
nutritional information for a specific
kind of food for example some of these
are very detailed as you can tell how
they're cooked and what ingredients they
may have in them as well as on some
specific cuts of meat or even specific
products of food since last year we've
added a lot more foods I think we had
about 30,000 now we have almost a
hundred thousand now so we're really
adding a lot of foods as we go along
there's a lot of nutritional properties
we have which come in a variety of
flavors including relative ones which
are sort of on a grand per gram basis so
you can compare foods that way or you
can compare on a typical serving size or
typical item size as well in addition in
addition to all of these nutritional
properties we have a lot of non
nutritional ones i like food types for
example which I'll cover in the next
slide and varieties and various things
with how these foods are all very
precisely organized and defined
and even we can make nice nutrition
labels out of them too so one of the
neat things we have is uh food types
which is which is a little fuzzier than
foods are which we need to have because
you know a hundred thousand foods are
really hard to navigate through so we
need about a much smaller fuzzy or sort
of thing to work with and these are food
types these do not have specific
nutritional information but they're
intended as sort of a navigation tool
and so they have a lot of non
nutritional properties as you can see
here so things like almonds bananas
apples oranges those sorts of things we
even have a lot of other things that you
might not even think or even related to
this stuff like even related Pokemon for
example so you can do lookups on these
and this is kind of how we sort of
navigate through the domains by using a
new energy value feature which was
introduced in Mathematica 10 called
implicit entities and so that's
basically instead of having a string to
represent a single entity in the second
argument we now allow a list of rules
there which allows us to sort of zoom in
on what we want so in this case we have
we want to find foods whose preparation
is refried and food type is beans that
will give us a refried beans implicit
entity and so basically this is one
entity that sort of aggregates over all
of them on you can always get them back
by using random entity or entities and
of course if you query for a single
value you get one value back that's the
nice thing about having implicit
entities and you can do a lot of other
cool things too like you can grab all of
the most calorie dense foods that we
have which are mostly fast foods
naturally and we also have a lot of neat
things you can do with image collage and
those sorts of things using this sort of
technology here another important tool
that we need to have is in the instance
which is how we represent quantities of
food so you can take any entity here and
then in the second argument you can
specify how much you have so this is
basically 200 grams of refried beans and
so the if we have properties that depend
on depend on the content on how much you
have that's what we use it for so here
we have absolute properties that sort of
you can feed it how much you had and
then that way it will scale
appropriately from there and you can
even make nutrition labels out of this
sort of stuff too and if we have the
ability to do this we
you to also be able to group things
together and the way we do that is by
using entity group I won't talk too much
about this but it's basically the same
thing it's a further layer of grouping
that way so you can still get back a
nutrition label that way so this sort of
pretty much wraps things up on what I
more or less showed last year I turned
out a lot of the examples and neat
things there because we have a lot of a
lot more new stuff to show off as well
but you can also see more if you have a
QR code reader feel free to take a
picture that'll take you straight to it
also you can download this notebook or
even the notebook that I used last year
just on passable so it should be right
on there as well one of the things I
point out in a blog post here is how to
compare apples and oranges with a nice
manipulate I I've left the code in here
if you want to see it but it's a it's
also on there to compare things and
there's a lot of other neat stuff like
comparing frozen pizzas and various
things like that but to let's move
forward onto the new packaged food type
stuff that we have so we've added a lot
more packaged foods and we're slowly
adding in more and more properties than
what we had before one of the first and
most important probably is marketing
descriptions so you can kind of see the
sort of trends that we have so one of
the first things you can do is uh here's
a couple examples of them and so I went
and grabbed one of the first things you
do when you do natural language
processing type stuff is to grab the in
grams and delete the stop words and
those sorts of things so that's what
these sort of are so these are sort of
the one grams here the single words and
these are the by grams repairs of words
and then work three words together or
the three grams is you might call them
and as you can see a lot of these are
nutrition based over here lots of
calories and an organic and those sorts
of things too and there's a lot of that
sort of stuff in these as well you see a
lot of Department in agriculture that's
because they were inspected for various
things from the US Department of
Agriculture and so the police stop words
gets rid of the of which is why that
shows up so since it is um pumpkin
season it's kind of nice to be able to
go through and find out what food types
are related to these and so by looking
up pumpkin you can find all the
different food types go with that and
make a nice word cloud out of it and you
can see the pub pumpkin frequently shows
up with baby food for example a lot of
other food types
well but uh also since its you know
pumpkin spice season as a lot of people
call it there's a lot of other foods
that are related to pumpkin spice here
as well that show up and of course you
can do this for other things like for
example organic and natural which am uh
organic mostly shows up for baby food
and a wide range of things and natural
shows up for even more things not just
one in particular and you may want to
look at other holidays too and it turns
out that they're not very exciting
Halloween pretty much there's only candy
and for Easter related things there's a
little more variation but you know it's
a little more variety there so moving
forward a little more we've added a lot
more international foods as well we've
added about 25,000 of them actually from
about 20 countries and so here's a nice
little jew region value plot that shows
off how many we have in each country in
Europe there's a lot of detailed
nutritional information for all these
things as you might expect I will make
this a little easier to see here so
there's just a couple here that we can
create a nice large Nutrition Facts
labels for and we also have translations
in multiple languages it's a little hard
to see here I can blow it up it doesn't
show up quite so well on here but we
have translations from the original
language that they were from as well as
those in English as well so we have all
of the English names up here since most
of our users generally speak English we
keep those here but we can also allow
access to the original names from what
from which they were translated with a
simple property qualifier which is shown
here so in order to do some of this
stuff when we deal with lots of foods we
need to have some sort of alignment with
these non nutritional properties that we
had before like food types and those
sorts of things it turns out a lot of
work like that for these international
foods has already been done for us which
is using a mod languid thesaurus which
has about 7,000 terms they're all very
detailed and translated in over seven
languages most of them
and they include cooking methods food
sources and those sorts of things and so
we're aligned to those almost we're in
the process of aligning everything we've
got into that but these foods at least
are tagged up with them and so you can
see here these are all individual tags
so they're a very precise and they all
have individual codes so that way
internationally you can just know what
code it is and then they're all
translated in that way some of the neat
things you can do with this is that you
can look up various foods much in the
same way that you can do with the
implicit entities otherwise in this case
here we've set one up where we can find
out which country in Europe has the most
cheese and it turns out that that's
finland on italy also has quite a few
more but there's some neat examples that
you can do here to just look do some
quick lookups that way you can also do
some nice nutrient comparisons like you
can look at the calorie density of foods
so you can kind of compare these and you
can kind of see there's there isn't
really any real trend but it is neat
that there are some on one end versus
the other and they sort of are vary from
one place to the next moving forward
from the international foods we also
have a lot of cooking equipment that
we've curated we've got about 2700
cooking equipment items and we were
slowly adding more and more physical
properties to all these sorts of things
so you can do some nice lookups for
example here we can grab the five
smallest knives that we have which are
Baker's knife primers on knife and those
sorts of things and you can also make
some nice visualizations and the clear
outlier here is the pizza knife which
naturally pizzas are pretty big so you
need to have a pretty big knife to be
able to cut them very easily so moving
forward on these we also have in
addition to that we have a lot of images
for all these things so you can make
some nice image collages as well as word
clouds and so the nice thing about this
is that you can make word clouds that
actually have tool tips of the images on
them so you can kind of see what they
look like so this is all part of our
sort of way to move forward to get into
recipes and those sorts of things this
is one of the pit stops where I can
before we get that far
on so to move on from that we need to
talk about nutrients now so one of the
big things that we've introduced our
nutrients where we have Dietary
Reference intake types for for
determining how much you need so most of
these are defined in terms of risk of
deficiency versus risk of excessive
intake and so they're sort of defined on
what you need and how much you should
have and not to go too far and those
sorts of things we have properties that
we can use to grab that information
really really easily and make some nice
plots like this or you can see over how
old based on your age how much do you
need for a particular property for
example we even have some that are
customizable one here is the daily value
percent which gives you the ability to
look up given a certain amount of food
here how much of my daily value does
that satisfy and so here I've just got
50 grams of orange of an orange and then
that tells me that covers about forty
three percent of it all and of course we
can also do this visually to in a
similar fashion using compass plots
which if you were here last year will
you will have seen that I used this sort
of thing now we have a property for it
so that you can just do it right on the
fly there and you don't have to build it
yourself or anything it's built right
into it which is nice and that way you
can compare foods and and those sorts of
things as well and the nice thing is you
can also hold your mouse over it'll tell
you how much you have on each one rather
than just giving you a visual overview
as well like I said it's also
customizable so you can actually
customize these to fit your diet as you
need them one of the things you can do
is you can use the property qualifiers
to be able to specify it I'll show a
little bit of the detail here using
these qualifiers you can specify your
gender if you're pregnant or not you can
also specify what nutrients you want to
use as well as your age so that you can
customize these plots to be however you
need you can even use different dietary
reference intakes types that I mentioned
before so not just the daily value but
you can also use maybe the estimated
average requirement or something or if
you're really worried about going over
how much you've used you can also use
the taller tolerable upper intake level
that way moving forward I guess the last
thing I'll point out real quick before
any sorts of questions and those sorts
of things I'll sort of put all this
stuff together to be able to create a
meal tracking application which I won't
really show too much here right now but
the idea is basically that we create a
web form which I've included some code
and it uses data bin to be able to store
this information and access it and so
it's a relatively simple code to use
where you can type in how much you had
type in the food and using interpreter
its able to understand it and you can
even set up other things like you know
what you ate when you ate it in those
sorts of things and it's very easy to
set up and use the same sort of barcode
scanner that I had showed last year in a
simple web form so on your phone you can
just take a picture and have it upload
it into it and use it there so it's a
quick thing there I'll also point out
that you can do some nice visualizations
with this while here I've used some
vertical gauges set up so you can kind
of visualize what's happens over the
past week I've put in a couple
properties here a couple nutrients so
here is a vitamin C this is sodium and
this is potassium and that's iron so
just as a quick example you can kind of
see that every morning I have a glass of
apple juice which more than satisfies my
requirement which is why the bar is full
most the time but you can see other days
where it's not so much here when I when
I don't do that and have maybe water or
something else in the morning instead so
this is a neat way to be able to sort of
track your diet and you can do many
other things than just this sort of
thing and with that i guess i will wrap
things up and give a quick reviews
basically i showed you what i did last
year with some of the food domains some
entity value features the apple some
applications and a link to the blog post
that i did it shows a little more
information there some show some of the
new food data that we've done with
packaged foods international foods and
cooking equipment and also some nutrient
type stuff things that you can do there
in a brief overview and sub-code with
veal tracking type stuff so at that
point I guess I will open it up for
questions thanks
you
[Applause]